feedback it's been a while what about
doing the graphs you might have seen
something like this now if you don't
remember it
I'm reminding you now this is the
equation of a circle the equation of a
circle you've read off the features of
this circle is a very small way to how
you read off the features of this
parabola I look and I say the center is
going to be at negative 1/3 you really
need in fact pretty much the identical
way they're like swapping the signs
around ok so you say the sensors are
negative 1 2 3 some of you might
remember it well how to read off the
radius of the circle the radius is
square root of this number so this case
it will be fun now this is a nice deep
form just like this is a nice thing hope
you've got the numbers that are
important just there on the surface ok
so as you can see sometimes you don't
get these give it to you in a nice neat
form they can denote beautiful but you
have to do some work to get there okay
so this here is a garbled mess that
comes from if you took this time and
expanded everything ok that's what you
in WC deserve magnets it's just
somebody's expanded this and this is
what they ended up with so our task is
to try and unscramble what's happened
find out something like this is where
you came from how do I get there what
just because I knew this is gonna happen
this what we would be waiting yet write
down and let me show you what to do I'm
going to as the name suggests
the squid here but I'm actually going to
do it we've me twice
he's wine look at the originally played
in two separate funky on
I like the prevalent different kind of
object you see there's not one but two
squares here on the left-hand side right
so there's an excellent business limit
and a wide something that's Swift so in
here this x squared Y squared term they
come fro through the difference web so
I'm going to complete blood sweat he's
how birthday all of the exit terms just
like I've been doing all day
I know I need to add something to make
oh you see where I sweat
I've just added for so all the way over
here on the other side of the equation
I'm gonna added or there as well okay
because I want to keep balance this big
here is then I'll swim its rate your
factorize what could do that yet but
more stuff to write in this line but I
will on the next month now I have a look
at the wine he's a wine turn he's
another Y turn this I complete the
square is why they used to see me axis
but it's just another letter so maybe I
could have called X or Y s home to you
idea lines look at the not much 25 your
heart that gave you five squared and 25
to the other side just added 25 to one
side so women stay balanced okay now see
this object to you that is a swing it 75
so I have a features mindette it mass
it's often very helpful to know where
you're going so you know what to do on
the way there
right do you see how the equation of
this circle all the numbers just numbers
they should end up on the right hand
side thing so she advise it doesn't
belong there it should be on the other
side so to keep it balanced I'm going to
add 35 to both sides it cancels with the
- anybody young and it just so I've got
a lot of things on that line from here
to be okay okay play this way and I put
this number where it belongs
[Applause]
in order to turn this into one that's
factor right I have it 45 here to turn
this into what's fine
and lastly I need to add up every view
of that right hand side which looks to
me like if you get this abyss over maybe
you can just read off the vertex I've
just read off the set up and the radius
R the symptom what's the exponent
positive 2 it's the opposite of that guy
the y-coordinate is anyone
negative 5 is the opposite of that guy
and of course you can also see radius
and Anchorage is just
angels
sir this is why conveniently back to the
graphing topic if the MLS you grab the
circle we always say that you'd like
this because I gave if I can see like
that you'd be like we're doing that I
don't know all the bits and pieces but
now that you don't know you complete the
square you can see it's useful in these
other ways you can analyze problems you
can find the vertex you can find a
center